today is the third day of this uh
excellent
series of talks by anker moytra from mit
and he's telling us about recent
advances in high dimensional learning
today supervised learning with mass art
noise so take it away ankur
great thanks for coming everyone so um
just to put this in context of some of
the other talks in this tutorial
so last time i talked about provably
robust
algorithms for parametric learning so
those were really
in an unsupervised learning setting
where you're positing some type of
structure in your data things like
you know the uncorrupted data is
gaussian or has bounded moments
that allow you to cope with corruptions
to your data
provably and in a computational
efficient manner so that you can still
learn things like
you know what's the mean what's the high
dimensional covariance of your data
so today's talk will be about pushing
back on some of those
assumptions because you know just like
there's unsupervised learning there's
supervised
learning where we're given a bunch of
data along with labels
and you know in supervised learning
sometimes you do and sometimes you don't
want to make generative assumptions
about where your examples come from
so that's what i'll be talking about
today is you know what can you do in
supervised learning
when you don't want to make strong
distributional assumptions on your
underlying data
is there still some sense in which you
can design
provably robust learning algorithms and
here it'll be an interesting story about
you know the strength of different types
of noise models
and the question will really be about
finding the sweet spot that's both a
rich model for noise and we can actually
say something algorithmically
interesting even in distribution
independent
settings so let me start off by
telling you about the classic framework
for talking about supervised learning
this goes back to les valion's famous
paper back in 1984
in which she introduced the pac learning
mode so here's how the back learning
model
works so we're given samples which are x
y
pairs you're thinking about x as being a
high dimensional vector
and you think about the distribution on
x as being arbitrary
a lot of times so there's some unknown
arbitrary distribution
on high dimensional vectors and y is a
label that's plus one or minus one
now the truth is you can think about
richer labels than just plus one or
minus one you can think about labels
from some discrete
or even continuous set but let's keep it
simple so they'll just be plus minus 1
today and the other assumption that you
make
is that there is some known hypothesis
class
capital h and there's some unknown
hypothesis
little h that lives in that class and
that all of your labels
fit that hypothesis so for each y that
you observe
y is equal to h of x so let's see what
this framework looks like with some
concrete examples so
one of the most important and
fundamental classes of hypotheses is
the class of all half spaces so what you
do is that there's an unknown vector w
star and there's potentially an offset b
and now when you're given a high
dimensional vector x you take the inner
product between w
star and x and you add the offset b and
then you take the sine
so you output plus one if it's positive
minus one if it's negative
and you know you can figure out what to
do if it's zero you could just
say you output plus one in that case so
geometrically what your data looks like
is it
lives in some dimensional space in this
case it's two dimensions
and then everything that's above the
half space is labeled with a plus one
and everything below your half space is
labeled with a minus one
now this is actually sometimes called
the realizable case because you're
making a very strong assumption really
that there is an actual hypothesis
within your family
that perfectly fits your data so
ultimately looking ahead in this talk
we'll be pushing back on that idea what
happens when there isn't a hypothesis
that perfectly fits the data
but for now let me tell you about the
way that these problems are usually set
up
so that was your generative model you
get to push a button and you observe
x comma y pairs and your goal is to
estimate
h approximately so what do i mean by
that you can't
really hope to learn the true hypothesis
because
even in the simple example there are
other linear separators that perfectly
fit the data
so instead what your goal is to estimate
h approximately you want to output
another hypothesis
h hat that has the property that it
almost entirely agrees with the
underlying hypothesis h
so this is called probably approximately
correct learning that's why it's called
the pac model
so you allow yourself some failure
probability delta maybe you just got
really unlucky with the samples you're
given
and you want your learning algorithm to
be approximately correct in the sense
that it outputs another hypothesis
that agrees with most of the data that's
coming out
from your generative model
okay so there are tons of very powerful
learning algorithms that are known in
the context of
pac learning but now what i want to talk
about is something that fits in with the
last lecture i gave which is
you know what happens if there's noise
or to phrase it a different way is you
know what happens you're faced with this
very realistic possibility
that there's no simple hypothesis like a
linear separator
that fits your data exactly and now
we're going to reach
you know some forking paths here because
there are a few different ways that you
can think about
what this noise looks like let's start
off with the easiest model for noise the
easiest one to cope with
so one thing that could happen is that
each label could be
flipped independently with some fixed
probability let's say a third
now this is called random classification
noise and if i did flip the labels
randomly and independently with some
probability
let's say a third i might get some
collection of data that looks like this
now there's a problem which is that my
class of hypotheses
is the set of linear separators the set
of half spaces
but there is no half space that
perfectly fits the data
at best there's a half space that agrees
quite well
with the data now it turns out that in
random classification noise models there
actually are powerful learning
algorithms
one of the seminal works in this area is
the work of blum it all back in 98
and some of the intuition which we'll
get into a bit later because it's going
to come up in other guises in
our analysis is that there are a lot of
iterative algorithms and standard pack
learning things like the perceptron
algorithm
and there's a sense in which a lot of
those iterative algorithms like
perceptron that make some kind of
progress with each step when they don't
haven't reached a good hypothesis
well if your noise really were
independent and random
you would still have some nice progress
and expectation where you're converging
to the true
half space that you wanted to learn so
that's some of the intuition and all it
is is intuition for now
but you know what happens if we go to
the other end of the spectrum because
the truth is that
assuming that the noise is independent
and homogeneous across your domain
is actually a really strong assumption
that sometimes
is just not really a realistic thing to
do
so at the very other end of the spectrum
is what's called
agnostic learning so that was like what
i talked about last time because
last time when i talked about
unsupervised learning problems like
learning a high dimensional gaussian
it was in an agnostic model because i
made no assumptions on how the adversary
was corrupting the data
he just had a finite budget epsilon
fraction the data that he was allowed to
corrupt
same thing happens here is that there's
no assumption about the structure of the
noise
instead what you want to do is that if
the way that the adversary has added
noise
still has the property that there's a
half space that agrees
with the data quite well you want to
find one that has
approximately the best agreement in the
class
so if for some reason the way that the
adversary added noise to your data
preserve the fact that there was a half
space that 99
agrees with your data then you want to
find a half space that
agrees with let's say 98 of your data
that's agnostic learning
and again it's called agnostic because
you're not trying to make a religious
assumption that
there is a hypothesis that perfectly
fits your data or that the noise is
independent like it is in the random
classification noise
model now unfortunately there's a
problem which is that agnostic learning
and supervised learning problems is
generally pretty darn hard
so we we basically only know results
that make some kind of distributional
assumption
on their inputs so you know there's a
beautiful classic work of kalai clivens
monsoor and cervedio
and some improvements that were really
powerful due to awasti balkan and long
that showed that there's a polynomial
time algorithm for agnostically learning
half spaces
when x is gaussian actually the
difference between these results is that
so your goal is to try and get
a half space that agrees up to accuracy
opt
plus epsilon were opt as the best
agreement and collided all gave an
algorithm that ran in time d
to the poly and epsilon and then
ostheatal in the specific case of x
being gaussian
we're able to improve it to a polygon
whenever epsilon times poly and d time
algorithm now the trouble is that this
generally is what you have to do in this
space
is that when you're trying to do
agnostic learning well if you don't make
any distributional assumptions not only
do we not
know any algorithms out there generally
speaking
it's also true that there are hardness
and there are lower bound results so one
recent lower bound of danielle
shows distribution independent lower
bounds for agnostically learning half
spaces in fact it's even a little bit
worse because
in his setup there is the promise that
there's a half space that agrees with 99
of your data but it's hard
computationally to find a half space
that agrees with 51 percent of your data
so that's weak agnostic learning
so the main focus of this talk will be
are there challenging noise models where
we can
learn without making distributional
assumptions on x
so i talked about two ends of the
spectrum one was the purely
random noise model and the other was one
where we made no assumptions about the
noise whatsoever the agnostic model
but they're things that fit in between
them that potentially fit the bill
of being challenging noise models and
yet allowing
provable algorithms to work so in this
talk
the main thing that we'll be interested
in is a model that i quite like
it's called the massart noise model in
which
here's the way that it works is that you
think about
each point x you know that's one of your
examples
it's going to have its label flipped
independently with some probability eta
of x
now this probability eta of x is upper
bounded by some eta
that's an upper bound of the noise rate
across the entire domain so you can
think about eta as being a third
now the point is that the noise is still
independent across the different points
x but it no longer has the property that
it's homogeneous so it can actually vary
over different parts of the domain
[Music]
so there's one interpretation of the
miss art noise model that'll help you
wrap your head around it and then i'll
give you an alternative interpretation
that i'm very partial to that's
not quite the same thing but it's
morally the same thing
so you can think about it this way as
imagine that you started off with your
random classification noise model
where you flip each label independently
with probability eta
so you flip every label with probability
a third but now what you
allow an adversary to do is he's allowed
to unflip
the label to actually make it the
correct label if he so wants
it turns out that many algorithms like
the blum at all algorithm that work
in the random classification noise model
they're actually quite brittle in the
sense that when an adversary is allowed
to undo
some of the noise their guarantees
completely break down
so that's one of the surprising things
and that's why the goal is to find
something that hits the sweet spot of
being a flexible noise model while still
permitting
efficient algorithms there's another
interpretation that i really like
i wrote here sort of because it's
actually not literally the same thing
but it turns out that all of the
algorithms that i'll be describing that
work in the massage noise model will
also work
in this interpretation as well so
instead what you can think about is you
can think about the adversary as being
allowed to adversarially control
the labels in your data the catch is
that it's
it's a random fraction of your data so
instead what happens is that
there's a random data fraction of your
data where the adversary is now
allowed to control whether the label is
plus one
or minus one
and the main question i'll be interested
in is are there distribution independent
algorithms for learning with massage
noise
[Music]
so now let me tell you about some uh
recent results in
uh distribution independent massage
learning so there's a beautiful paper of
diaconicolas guliakis and
tamzos which showed that there is a
polynomial time algorithm for
improperly learning half spaces under
massage noise
so and they get error eta plus epsilon
where remember eta is the upper bound
on the flip probability that the
adversary is allowed on each one of the
data points
now their algorithm is actually quite
complicated in the sense that it outputs
something that's
not a half space instead what it outputs
is something which partitions the entire
domain
into a polynomial number of regions and
there's potentially a different half
space
on each one of these regions
so that's the sense in which it's
improper
is because it's not outputting an actual
hypothesis but something that's a much
more
complicated description of of the
classifier that you're using
and one of the natural questions you can
ask is is there a proper
learning algorithm so is there an
algorithm for properly learning half
spaces
under message noise now there's
also another limitation of this which is
that all of the classic results in
agnostic learning that worked for
distribution dependent
setups like having x being gaussian or
log concave
they all got error opt plus epsilon
where opt was the optimal agreement of
anything in your class so this
guarantee only gives you an error
guarantee of eta plus
epsilon where eta is the upper bound on
the error probability
that the adversary has added so in
principle you could hope for
a better error guarantee because maybe
it's possible to compete with the best
agreement
along among all half spaces within your
class
[Music]
so in some very recent work which i'll
delve into
so we gave a polynomial time algorithm
for properly learning half spaces
under massart noise up to the same error
eta plus epsilon
and what's kind of cool is that um you
know the earlier
paper of diaconicolasadol actually gave
a no-go theorem
for certain types of frameworks for
learning but we're actually going to
give a general framework
for learning under mossart noise that's
going to be it'll give you a good
conceptual understanding i think of
you know how exactly you can cope with
things like massage noise
i should mention that this framework was
independently discovered by diaconicolas
cantonus tsamos and zaryfus
in a paper which handled distribution
dependent learning
under sipikov noise which i won't get
into
but one of the cool upshots of this
general framework that i'm going to give
you in this talk
is that it also works for much richer
families of hypotheses
so there are things you can do that are
pretty interesting that are beyond
half spaces that you can still do under
massage noise
like there's something called a
generalized linear model that we
actually saw in lancas talk
just about an hour ago and what a
generalized linear model
is is that there's an unknown vector w
star
and for each data point x we take the
inner product between w star and x and
we add the offset b
so same setup as a as a half space
but now we apply some function sigma
that's called the link function
and the constraints that we impose on
this link function are that it's
monotone
and lip sheets in particular this
includes things like
noisy logistic regression when you plug
in sigma being a sigmoidal function
as a special case so these are all
things that you can do
in supervised learning without
distributional assumptions on x
actually under rich models of noise like
the massart noise model
now i'll just uh tell you a little bit
more about the landscape of you know
massart noise and
what's known because and i won't get too
much into this in the talk but it
actually turns out that there are some
pretty surprising connections between
learning with mozart noise and something
called evolvability that les valiant
introduced a few years ago
and one of the things that we showed was
that lower bounds for evolvability
turn out to imply lower balance for
learning under massage noise
so one of the remaining questions which
i posed is whether you can
compete with the optimal agreement it
turns out that you can prove lower
bounds in a natural framework for
algorithms called statistical query
lower bounds
that there's no polynomial time
algorithm for learning under massage
noise
up to error opt plus epsilon with a
polynomial number
of samples and runtime
and actually this connection goes the
other direction that you can actually
use
algorithms in evolvability to give new
distribution
uh you can actually get new distribution
dependent
evolutionary algorithms that are
resilient to drift again i won't get
into that
all right so i'm going to take a step
back and tell you a little bit about
you know how to think about learning
with different kinds of noise models
because i really have to start from the
basics
about how you learn without noise and
what kinds of convex surrogates are
tailored to work with different kinds of
noise models even things like random
classification noise
so i'm really going to present a
different way of thinking about some of
the earlier results
and that'll be the way we pedagogically
build up towards being able to tolerate
mossart noise and design some sort of
general framework for thinking about
algorithm design in the space
so let's uh let's start from the basics
right so
in pack learning our goal is to get low
error in terms of something called the
zero one loss
right so we can think about outputting
some hypothesis w
and just for simplicity i'm going to
assume that there's no
offset b it's you know you can do that
actually without loss of generality in
these setups
but if i think about my hypothesis w so
that the hypothesis that it defines is i
take my vector
x my example i take its inner product
with w
and i take the sine of that that spits
out a plus one or minus one
and i want to know how often that agrees
with the true label y
that i see this is the zero one loss
because either you get zero loss because
you got the right label
or you get a loss of one because you got
the wrong label
now you can think about this a few
different ways this will be a convenient
way to think about it is in terms of
indicator functions
so if i take w transpose times x
and then i multiply it by minus y and i
take the indicator function
of whether that is non-negative or not
that's actually the same thing as the
zero one loss
because remember what i want is i want
the sign of the inner product between w
and x
to agree with y and if it did then the
product of those
two would be positive and then i take
the extra minus sign outside
it would be negative so this loss would
pick up a zero when i use the indicator
function
and if i got the label wrong i would
pick up a one
so this is how you can think about the
zero one loss through indicator
functions
and now we can visualize what's
happening because we take
all of our data which are really xy
pairs and what we plot in 1d
is we take the inner product of w and x
and we multiply by minus y
and all of our examples land somewhere
along the line
when i apply this function and this
indicator function just looks like the
step function
and wherever the example lands that's
what we pay if it lands on the positive
side then we pay
one for the loss and if it lands on the
negative side it means that it's a
correctly labeled example and we pay
zero
in our zero one loss
so now what's the main difficulty in you
know classic supervised learning we
always want to learn in the zero one
loss or almost always
but the trouble is that the step
function
is non-convex as a function of w
you know it's very clear from the way
that i've drawn it it's non-convex when
you think about its dependence on this
underlying vector w so what's the
standard thing that you do
in computational learning theory is you
define a convex relaxation
so this is a little bit different than
you know if you're from approximation
algorithms the sense in which you use
convex relaxations
is really they're called convex
surrogates because you want to create
some other convex function
that behaves almost the same as the loss
that you really want to minimize
so this is what leads to what's called
the relu loss so it looks
almost the same as that description of
the zero one loss that i
gave you earlier you know that version
with the indicator function
the only difference is that i multiply
by the magnitude
of the inner product between w and x
so that's the relay loss we can do the
same thing as before we plot all of our
examples
we apply this function where we map them
to minus y times the inner product of w
and x
and they land somewhere along this real
line
and now what does the relu loss pay well
any time it's
negative that indicator function is
turned off so you pay
nothing but the key point is that when
it's
positive what you pay isn't the same
thing it's not always this fixed value
one instead it's just a line of slope
one
because as you get this magnitude more
larger and larger that's sort of like
you know you're
you're really wrong in what you
predicted you thought that the inner
product would be
you know something very large but you
got the sign wrong so you pay something
that's related to the magnitude
of that so now the upshot of the relu
loss
is twofold first the reload loss is
convex
now as a function of w so i can actually
just
run an off-the-shelf solver like
gradient descent for actually minimizing
this convex function
that's how you derive things like the
perceptron algorithm that's where these
iterative algorithms come from
is they actually come from you know
convex surrogates
but the other thing is that actually i
claim achieving
zero loss on the relu loss function is
equivalent to fitting the examples
perfectly
right because you know if it's possible
to achieve zero
error in the zero one loss than it is in
the relay loss to because they agree
perfectly on the left-hand side
of the x-axis and you know the only
difference is that when you don't
perfectly agree
the relu loss and the zero one loss
differ in how large your loss is
right so now let's explore this issue
and come back to some of the questions
that i started off with you know what
happens when we add noise so we no
longer are in this realizable case where
there is a half space
that perfectly agrees with our data or
equivalently
we're no longer in a setting where the
minimum
of the relu loss really is zero because
maybe there's no half space that
perfectly fits our data
according to either the zero one loss or
the relu loss
now if you think about it you know what
ends up happening let's
imagine that these are my pre-noise data
points so
you know beforehand i have the correct
hypothesis and it perfectly fits my data
but now what happens if i add random
classification noise
i might do something like take one of
the extreme examples and flip it
all the way to the other side so what's
the problem with this is that
the relu loss is really large now it's
way way way larger than the zero one
loss
so it's not representative of how many
examples you're getting wrong
because when the relu loss is large it
could be that there's just a single
example that you've gotten
extremely wrong and alternatively when
the relay loss is small
it doesn't guarantee you have small zero
one loss because you could have tons of
examples you get wrong
they're just very close to the decision
boundary
right so you could just to summarize you
could incur a huge loss for a single
mistake
or incur a tiny loss if there are many
mistakes as long as they're close
to this y-axis so
just minimizing the relu loss even in
the case of having random classification
noise
does not work and that's part of behind
what this plum at all paper had to do
now it turns out that the blomidol paper
had a very complicated hypothesis that
it learned because
much like the diaconicolis at all paper
it partitioned space into a bunch of
different regions
now afterwards there were a lot of
simpler versions of it
one particularly like nice paper was due
to adam collie
which showed that one way you can think
about how to solve the problem
in the case of random classification
noise is just to change your surrogate
so instead of using the relu loss
function you use something that's called
the leaky relu
now it's pretty simple i think the
hardest thing about the leaky relu is
you know what the word leaky has to do
with it but here's what it looks like
pictorially
so it ends up having a slight slope
you know and it's off that slope is
slightly off from what the standard relu
was
so what you do is this uh loss function
looks basically the same like the leaky
relay you still have this indicator
function
you still have this absolute value of
the inner product term
but the difference is that there's a
parameter lambda and you subtract it
from the indicator function
so now if this indicator function were
off meaning that you actually got the
label of the example correct when you
use w
as your hypothesis instead of getting no
loss you actually get a negative loss
you get a slight gain
and in fact you get an even larger gain
if you're further and further
from the decision boundary so now what's
the intuition for
why this works in terms of the random
classification noise model
is that if you had an example that's far
from the decision boundary
well there's some chance that you get it
right that the noise
you know isn't added to that example and
then you incur a pretty positive gain
because it's far from the decision
boundary
if you choose lambda in the right way
that's actually perfectly offset
by the big loss that you incur when it
flips over the decision boundary
so the way that this works is that if
there's some eight of flip probability
there is a way to set
this parameter in the leaky relu so that
actually minimizing the leaky real
loss works for the random classification
noise model
and that's the modern proof of how you
get the blomidol
results how you get algorithms that work
with random noise
so now let's make things harder on
ourselves because random noise
isn't all there is that's actually a
very very strong assumption
so what i want to do is i want to
introduce you to a new way to think
about
how to design provably robust algorithms
specifically in the context of
supervised learning
and we're going to do it through a
two-player zero-sum game that's going to
be our framework for
you know what it means to learn and what
it means to
find you know some region in space where
we're doing poorly and we haven't
yet reached a good hypothesis
[Music]
so let me start from a two-player game
that's not actually going to work
but it's the conceptually right place to
start
so i'm going to create a very very
complicated two-player game
so what i do is there'll be two players
one player the min player is looking for
a direction w
remember that the direction w represents
the hypothesis we want to learn
that's why we take the inner product
between w and x and we multiply by minus
y
and we plug that all into the leaky relu
but now something kind of funny is going
to happen is that we're not
merely interested in the leaky relu loss
we're going to create a max player
who is allowed to re-weight the
distribution so he's allowed to create
an arbitrary distribution c
on space of arbitrary complexity
and then you look at the expectation of
c of x times the leaky relu loss
so that's the intuition is that the max
player is allowed to re-weight the
distribution on examples to focus
on some particular region in space where
we're doing poorly
so that the idea is that if you think
about this massage noise model
while the true hypothesis w is not only
good in terms of zero
one loss but it also has the property
that even if you restrict to any part of
space
it still does well and that's because
the errors that the adversary has added
you know
are randomly scattered over space now
they might not be entirely random
because
remember the second interpretation of
the stark noise model was that
a random aida fraction of the data is
where the adversary chooses
where to add the corruptions whether to
make the label plus one or minus one
but the key point is that it's somewhat
homogeneous over space where those
corruptions
could be at least in principle
so the intuition is that this max player
is going to choose some distribution
that hones in on the part where your
current hypothesis is doing really
poorly
[Music]
so you know the intuition now you know
just to sort of phrase it a different
way is that
while you might do well overall
according to the leaky relu because the
adversary has added
less overall noise this max player can
now always restrict you to where you're
doing poorly and that can force you to
try and find a better hypothesis in
terms of agreement with the data
now there's a simple claim that i'm not
going to prove because this isn't really
the zero sum game i want to work with
what i claim is that if we could reach a
minimax optimal solution for this
two player zero sum game then the
optimal solution for the min player
would actually be the true
unknown direction w star so this is the
sense in which the zero-sum game is at
least a reasonable thing to do
but there's another sense in which it's
a very ill-posed way of thinking about
things
because let's think about what's going
on inside the zero-sum game
so first of all optimizing over the max
player strategies
is computationally hard because we're
optimizing over all
distributions over all of space in fact
it's also statistically hard because i
would just have to take
an infinite number of examples to really
evaluate what this expectation is
so this zero sum game you know doesn't
really work for us because it's just
statistically and computationally
unwieldy
so the miraculous thing is that there's
going to be a new version of the game
that will work instead of the max player
is choosing an
arbitrary distribution over all of space
he's only going to be allowed to
reweight the distribution in some very
specialized ways
so imagine that the min player chooses
some hypothesis w
and again we have this leaky relu loss
that we look at an expectation
but now what the adversary is going to
do is he's only allowed to restrict the
distribution
to some slab along w so you take your
data and you project it along w the
current hypothesis for the min player
and you restrict the distribution to the
slab of all points
which land in between minus r and plus r
so now all of a sudden the max player is
actually computationally efficient
because once the min player chooses the
w
this is just a single one-dimensional
line search to find his best response
it's also statistically efficient what's
not at all obvious
is the thing which really is the main
part to show
is that this zero-sum game is still good
enough any approximate equilibrium
actually does correspond to a hypothesis
w that has
low error so that's the miraculous part
and this is really a general framework
that you can try for
other kinds of uh generalized linear
models
and it's just a way to think about how
to cope with mozart noise as you want to
play a minimax game
against someone else who's allowed to
pick out parts of your distribution in a
very specialized way
and say aha you're doing poorly here do
better
[Music]
all right so let me tell you about some
other classic things and computational
learning theory to build up towards the
analysis the truth is the analysis is
actually
pretty darn simple so i'm going to be
able to give you the full analysis
uh today in fact you know parts of it
are going to borrow on the earlier work
so i'll explain how those things worked
at least some of the key lemmas from
them
so first we have we need this
fundamental notion called the margin
many of you will have probably heard it
but let me just define it anyways
so the mar the margin is the smallest
distance of any example
from the decision boundary so
pictorially what does it look like
remember when we have the zero one loss
we plot the examples according to where
they fall on the real line
and the margin is just the width of this
interval how close any example
is the decision boundary which
corresponds to the case where
you know along the real line you're
looking at the zero point
so the key lemma we're only going to
have two key lemmas and that'll actually
complete the proof
of the thing modulo one minor extra
detail
and let me tell you the first key level
we can actually borrow it from some
previous work
so key lemma number one due to diacona
cholesterol
is that in the massage noise model let's
say you choose your lambda parameter
which remember is the parameter in the
leaky relu loss
and you choose it in such a way that
it's at least as large as eight of the
upper bound on the noise rate
and your distribution on x has some
special property that it has margin at
least
gamma then what i claim is that if you
plug in the true w
star into your leaky relu loss
that it will have low loss in fact it'll
have
negative loss according to the leaky
relu loss where your upper bound depends
on the margin
it depends on this parameter llama in
your leaky relu loss and it depends on
the
error of the true w star
so this is the first key lemma and this
lemma is
super short i mean the proof isn't even
going to take up this full slide
it's just a matter of actually writing
out the definition and remembering
what the descriptions of the leaky relu
loss are
so the first thing that i'm going to do
is i'm going to write out the leaky
loss using that expression that i did
before in terms of the indicator
function
and this lambda parameter times the
absolute value of the inner product
between w star and x
right the only trick is that what i'm
going to do is i'm actually going to use
sub conditioning
so first the first expectation is its
expectation is over x
the draw from the domain and this
remaining probability is on the
randomness
of the noise you know let's work on that
first interpretation where
the adversary adds some noise eta of x
that's independent across each one of
the data points and is upper bounded by
eta
so this is all it's using is the
definition of the leaky relu loss and
the notion of subconditioning
so now what do we do well this
probability that the true w star agrees
with the label that we observed
is equal to eta of x which is upper
bounded by eta
which itself is less than lambda by
assumption
so in fact when we plug in this um
you know what this means is that this
entire term is negative
so instead we can plug in the lower
bound on the margin
and that's going to give us an upper
bound on the leaky relu loss
that's it that's the first key lamp
and we only have one more key lemma to
go until we're done with the analysis
so abstracting what this key limit tells
us it tells us that the true direction w
star
achieves small loss that's good that's
an important property in even the setup
of our zero sum game
and one point i want to point out is
just the conceptual point in this right
is that you know what's also true is
that imagine that we take our problem
and we restrict the domain in some way
we stick to a slab we restrict in some
other way
this analysis would still carry over
because we would just have a different
distribution on x
so this is the part of the massage noise
model that we're really exploiting is
that
this type of proof and this type of
analysis even works under restriction
and just emphasize this is not at all
true for agnostic learning
because in agnostic learning where the
adversary is allowed to add
an arbitrary ada fraction of corruption
and distribute them over space
however he sees fit he can concentrate
them in some part of the domain
and when you restrict the part of the
domain that part of the domain might
have a much worse error rate than the
rest of the domain
so this is one conceptual difference
between the massage noise model and the
agnostic model
and we can see where exactly it comes
out in the analysis
even in such a simple key lemma as this
so i'm half done because i only have one
more key lemma
left to go so let me tell you the key
lemma
that we're going to need to complete you
know this analysis of
why reaching an equilibrium in this game
is good enough to solve the learning
problem
and this is actually a simplified
version of the lemma that's in our paper
what i claim is the following if you're
in the missouri noise model
suppose the error of your current
hypothesis w
and by error i mean the 0 1 loss is
larger than lambda where again
lambda is the parameter of your leaky
relu loss
then what i claim is that there is some
slap remember a slab is defined by
direction w
and some threshold r where you look at
points between minus
r and r there is some slab
where the leaky relu loss restricted to
just the portion of the distribution
that falls within that slab
is large so we know that the true w star
has negative
loss and yet by virtue of the fact that
w has large
error this loss on some bad slab
is actually too large it's not only not
negative it's actually
positive potentially so what does this
mean if we can prove this key lemma
[Music]
well what it means is that if the
current direction w
does not get small enough error then the
max player can do well in the game
because he can find a slab along the
current direction w
in which the leaky relu loss restricted
to that slab is large
larger than it should be
[Music]
and so in particular the converse to
this is that
if we're doing well with respect to the
min player that's actually equivalent to
achieving
small error that's the thing that we
actually care about for our learning
problem
so let's prove this key lemma this will
be you know the only remaining proof i
have left in this talk but then
i'll talk about some conceptual things
about this work
so you know suppose for the sake of
contradiction that there is no slab
where the leaky relu loss
is large there is no r right
so let's literally translate what that
statement means
that means for every r well when i plug
in the definition of what the leaky
ruler loss is looks like the same thing
it's got this indicator function minus
lambda
times this absolute value term and then
i have this indicator function of
whether or not the point
falls into the slab right and so
the you know for the sake of
contradiction if there's no slab where
the loss is large then for every r
this expectation is strictly negative
okay
and this is just the loss times the
indicator function of the slab nothing
much is going on here
[Music]
now we're just going to use a really
simple identity well
for any x that's positive that's the
same thing as integrating the indicator
function of whether y is less than x
along from y from 0 to infinity that's a
pretty simple integral identity
but the key point is that this identity
is going to allow us to absorb this
absolute value term inside this
indicator
by adding a new variable not y but the
variable s
and the result is that we integrate over
s
so if we absorb that inside we get this
identity and here again we've done the
same
subconditioning trick where the first
expectation is over x and the remaining
probability is over
the noise that happens that decides what
the actual label y is
now we're basically done because you
know that integral being strictly
negative
means that there's some value of s for
which the thing inside the integral is
negative two
so for any r there's some s of r where
that
term inside the integral is strictly
negative
and now we're actually done because we
can just rearrange we pulled the lambda
on the other side
this indicator function well if we
divide by the probability being in the
slab
we get a conditional probability of you
know the probability we get the sign
wrong conditioned on actually being in
the slab
and we know that lambda is a strict
upper bound for it
and that's a that's actually going to
give us a contradiction because now we
have a slab where
our hypothesis w is actually doing well
and we can chain together a bunch of
these regions we start with r
we find another s of r and that finds us
some slab where we're doing pretty well
in that slab
and that gives us a new r that we find a
new s of r and that gives us another
slab which we're doing pretty well
and if we chain together all of these
regions disjointly
then we get an upper bound on our error
that we really have found a good w
that achieves good 0 1 loss and that
completes the proof by contradiction
that's it
[Music]
so that was the most technical part of
the proof
um but you know my point was that it's
actually a very simple analysis
and now let's put this all together into
an actual
algorithm right because what we've said
so far is that we have a two player zero
sum game
where it suffices to reach a good
equilibrium
in order to solve the learning problem
that we care about even in a rich model
of noise like the massage noise
so now how do we actually find a good
equilibrium
well i mean probably many of you have
seen these kinds of things before
all we do is we do it iteratively we
start with some
guess for the min player randomly let's
say we choose w
randomly in the unit ball doesn't really
matter
and then what we're going to do is the
max player is going to try and do well
in response so the max player is going
to try and find a slab
let's call this slab defined by r star
that
maximizes the leaky relu loss on that
slab
now if the best the max player can do
really isn't all that well because the
best slap he found
only has loss at most epsilon then what
our key lemmas tell us is that
it suffices just to return w because
the max player can't do well and the
only way that that's true is if
the w that we found right now really
does have small
error so we've solved our learning
problem what happens if
you know the max player does well he
finds a slab in which the loss is
actually quite large
well we want to learn from you know that
that loss
in fact what we do is we're going to
exploit the convexity of the loss
function
because we just take its gradient and we
take a step opposite to the gradient and
project back into the unit ball because
we care about a unit vector
w now the real version you have to care
about a lot of details like
you know sample complexity bounds using
the empirical loss and what have you
doesn't really matter those things do
work out but you know the key point in
why this type of thing converges in a
small number of steps
is that the leaky relay loss remember is
convex
as a function of w so what does it mean
when the max player has found an r star
where our leaky relu loss on that slab
is much
larger than the optimal thing w star
well when this left hand side is
actually quite large then
the fact that the leaky loss is convex
it means that there
there's a lower bound at the inner
product between the negative the
gradient
and the direction that points from you
know w to w
star and so when we have a large
left-hand side
that means that somehow when we're
playing the strategy w
against something that looks like the
gradient we're doing a lot
worse than we could have done in
hindsight if we just played w
star so this is actually what's called
online convex optimization which the
framework in online convex optimization
is that there's some convex body in our
case it's the unit ball because we look
you're interested in finding a w
that's in the unit ball and in each time
step the adversary plays a convex
function
in our case it's a very simple convex
function because it's
you know the gradient and what we incur
is we incur
the evaluation of a function at the
point that we play and the goal is to
compete with the best point in hindsight
so putting it all together every time
that this iterative game goes on
and you know the w that we play doesn't
work well
in you know when the max player responds
to us it means we're doing much worse
than we could have
and yet online gradient descent and
projected versions of it are known to
achieve low regret
so this actually can't happen for too
many time steps and that's actually how
you complete the analysis
so now in the few minutes that are left
what i want to do is i want to introduce
maybe a crazier idea
i'm not going to say that this
necessarily makes sense but it's
definitely something
that's worth exploring because it's very
intriguing
so you know maybe i want to address the
question
when are some noise models more
reasonable than others you know
massage noise certainly sounds hard to
get provable learning algorithms that
work with it
but you know what kind of setting is it
really helpful to try and work
with massage noise noise rates that vary
across the domain
and let me show you an experiment that's
motivated by questions about fairness
so when is this noise model of misart
noise useful
well let me tell you about an experiment
we did so we took this uci
adults data set and if you don't know
what this is let me explain
so there's about 50k individuals in it
now each individual
is defined by a vector of attributes
they're like 14 attributes things like
marital status education
level and what have you and the goal is
to take this vector of attributes for
each one of the individuals
and predict whether their yearly income
is above or below
50k so it's a pretty simple prediction
problem
[Music]
and we did something a little bit weird
here which is that you know there are
many different types of demographic
groups within this data set
so what we did was we added random noise
outside a target group
so we added noise to everyone else
except for some target group
and we ran off the shelf algorithms
whose goal is to get an accurate
classifier
and something kind of wild happened but
first let me motivate it
so you know one reason why you could
think about this noise rate
being different across different
demographic groups is actually there are
tons of empirical studies
showing that this indeed is the case
when you do things like you send out
surveys in the social sciences
it's well known that how accurate the
answers you get
vary across different demographic groups
it could have to do with you know
what types of language they're fluent in
it could have to do with whether they
trust
the system which the surveys are coming
from you know will it
actually be you know ultimately that
data be
used to for something that helps them or
will it harm them
sometimes people refuse to answer
surveys because they've had such a
set of negative experiences with you
know the government and what have you
and so we did was we we took the setup
where we added noise to
everything except for the target group
and we took
off-the-shelf algorithms that tried to
maximize the overall accuracy and we
measured
how those algorithms did in terms of
accuracy on that target group where we
hadn't added the noise
now something kind of wild happens if
you take for example like the target
group of
african americans then what you can do
is you can add
varying noise rates outside to everyone
else who's not in this demographic group
and you can take a bunch of
off-the-shelf algorithms like random
forest logistic regression
and you know algorithms that learn under
random classification noise and you can
see how well they do at the prediction
problem overall
over the entire group of samples and you
can see that you know they all achieve
about the same
overall accuracy for different noise
rates but
some of them do catastrophically worse
on small demographic groups within the
data
so in fact when you add 20 noise to
the entire population outside of this
target group
a bunch of these off-the-shelf things
like logistic regression
predict that almost no african-americans
from the group have income
above 50k this is pretty horrible
in fact it's horrible across a bunch of
different demographic groups when you do
female same thing happens and when you
do it with immigrants
same kinds of things happen although the
degree of this effect
varies across these different
demographic groups but what's nice is
that
our algorithms which are designed to
work
with noise rates that vary across the
domain or across different demographic
groups
they achieve the same overall accuracy
while not having this catastrophically
bad performance
on different target demographics so i'll
say that random forest does quite well
too
now random forests it's an interesting
open question to try and analyze it in
complicated noise models to understand
why it's doing so well
but it does have this downside that it's
actually much harder to interpret
because it doesn't output something as
simple as like a simple half space
but then again you know what is and
isn't interpretable is kind of
in the eye of the beholder so in summary
what we found from this experiment is
that many natural algorithms that are
designed
to achieve good overall accuracy what
happens is when they're faced with
varying noise rates across the domain
they tend to amplify biases in the data
this is something that i haven't seen
studied too much and in contrast
are algorithms which have provable
guarantees when the noise rates
vary these actually tend to do
empirically much better
and they do so even without knowing the
identity of these
protected groups that you want to make
sure you know are not
disadvantaged so let me take a step back
and
philosophize wildly about this so within
algorithmic fairness you know i'm an
outsider but there's tons of
really interesting stuff happening there
there are a lot of definitions like
equalized odds and calibration that
actually come from
normative considerations and a lot of
you know philosophy literature at their
core
that posit you know what you should ask
of your classifiers
but you know the truth is that often
they're pretty difficult to achieve in a
lot of settings
so i guess i'm asking a much more naive
question
which is in a lot of settings we might
have some idea
about what are the ways that you know
noise
enters into our data and the way that it
treats different subgroups differently
now can algorithms that are designed to
cope with these rich noise models
do something practically relevant
vis-a-vis fairness can they actually do
better
you know does making your algorithm
robust to richer noise models
empirically do things that make it you
know perform without these giant gaps
and performance
across different demographic groups
maybe because it can tolerate
heterogeneous noise
and for those of you know these kinds of
things you know just to tie this back in
even with some of the things
i talked about last time you might be
wondering how all of this fits in with
differential privacy see differential
privacy
algorithms are known to be robust and
they've even been used for fairness
but there's actually a difference in how
these problems are set up in the context
of learning theory and how they
tend to be set up you know within the
context of privacy
so in the context of privacy usually
your notion of what it means for an
algorithm to be differentially private
or be robust
is that if you change a small number of
examples you shouldn't change the output
of your classifier or statistical query
too much but here we're working at a
very different end of the spectrum which
is not when a constant number of
examples are corrupted
but when a constant fraction of examples
are corrupted
and instead we're making distributional
assumptions on our input
so these are actually quite different in
the sense that differential privacy is
not trying to make distributional
assumptions
and tries to tolerate a very small
number of changes in your data
a universal constant whereas a lot of
these questions that i've been asking
have been about
you know what can you do when you
actually posit a little bit more
structure in your data
is there a sense in which you can
actually tolerate some constant fraction
of noise so i'll stop there and
you know summarize what i hope you got
out of it so
you know there's a lot of interesting
stuff that's been done in robust
supervised learning
you can think about many different
models like random classification noise
agnostic noise models
the trouble is that as much as we would
like to do things in agnostic noise
generally it's hard to do it without
distribution or
guarantees on the inputs and what i was
trying to make the case of
is that there are interesting models
that are compromises in between them
where you can have rich noise models and
yet you can design
provably robust and computationally
efficient algorithms
so there's a ton of interesting stuff in
the space to explore i gave you some
generalizations to
generalize linear models although i
didn't show you how to prove them
and then i asked a wildly out there
question
which is you know all the stuff that
people have been doing in robustness
and robustness and unsupervised learning
robustness and supervised learning
it seems to me like you know one of the
stories that we can tell about noise
relates a lot to fairness considerations
i wonder if
any of these algorithms or even these
algorithmic insights
have anything to say so i'd love to hear
your inputs on that
so thanks for your attention just give
me one second i'm gonna i think my audio
is dead
okay uh thanks thanks anker for another
great talk um i guess there's a couple
of
questions that have popped up in the q a
so maybe we can start with those and if
you have a question that you want to ask
live
raise your hand and one of the hosts
will unmute you
hello can you hear me hey i'm sorry i
actually couldn't hear when you said
that would you mind repeating it
oh i just said let's start with the
questions in the q a and uh oh sure
yep and uh yeah okay
thanks horrible talk okay let's see uh
if the noise were actually
from the logistic model does your
algorithm still work
that's a great question so um this is a
pretty
technical one so uh let me do my best to
explain it
so what's kind of funny is that um this
uh this generalized linear model
remember that the setup for that was
that there's sigma
of w transpose times x
and actually it works in something
called the probabilistic concept model
because sigma is actually you know value
between -1 and 1. it's not a value of
you know necessarily of the two so
there's this thing called the
probabilistic concept model of kerins
and spiri
in which what you assume is that there
is a you know that that's the
expectation
of your label so that's the setup even
for the classic
you know generalized linear models and a
bunch of those things you can think
about
as subsuming random classification noise
because even if you had something like
an actual
you know indicator function was your
link function
then if you added random classification
noise
you can actually fold that into changing
the link function because you would just
move the expectation
closer to zero so a bunch of things
where you assume
something about where the noise model is
actually
simple like you know it's random or i
think
in your logistics setting you can
actually fold it into
the link function and you can just use
you know collides
algorithms for learning under
generalized linear models
that's also related to this other point
that i made that
you know doing gradient descent on the
leaky relu loss is the right way to
think about how to learn under rcm
that was actually the output of you know
one of collide's papers with sastry and
then sort of further clarified in one of
kalei's later papers
and it's also tied to some earlier
things in um
you know the machine learning literature
where they studied you know if you have
a link function
what's the notion of a matching loss
that has the property
that anything that minimizes the
matching loss
is necessarily a minimizer for the loss
that you care about
um and proving things like it has no
spurious local minima so a bunch of this
literature is sort of very convoluted i
can add a plug that i learned a bunch of
this stuff
obviously through my students but uh
through and they learned it through some
of roone kannaday's uh
excellent lecture notes that i think
helped give a modern perspective on it
mickey asks what happens if there is
some structure in the noise
probabilities
for instance the noise probabilities
adaf x are a decreasing
function of the distance from the
decision boundary but otherwise are
arbitrary
does this help that is a really good
question um i'm afraid i don't know much
about it
what i would believe i mean i'm happy to
be wrong if anyone knows anything else
in the literature that
works for those kinds of noise models
but you know just to
add a little bit of background at least
what i think about you know
whether that would be a tractable model
to work with or not
so at one end of the spectrum you could
make a parametric assumption here
because you could assume
something about how eta of x
depends on the distance from the
decision boundary like maybe it's a
function
of the of the of the distance the
decision boundary
and that actually might be doable
because
you know a lot of those parametric
models you can actually cope with like
some sort of structure about what your
noise looks like so i haven't seen
anything but
it sounds like a pretty algorithmically
tractable thing to try and study
but if you merely have a one-sided bound
that
the um the error probability is at most
this function of the decision
distance of the decision boundary then
it's really a non-parametric model for
the noise
and those things tend to be really nasty
to deal with something that is related
to something called the civica of noise
that doesn't encode anything about the
geometry but instead
posits some structure about the
distribution on what the eight as
x's look like across your entire
distribution you can't have too many of
them that are too close to a half
could you summarize the different
notions of robustness studied in
learning theory
okay so this is going to be a tough one
but let me at least start by summarizing
some of the notions of noise that i
talked about
so far in my two talks at least so first
there were notions of noise in
unsupervised learning models and there
was a whole cornucopia of what it means
for an adversary to corrupt data
because there are different versions of
the adversary depending on if they
choose their corruptions obliviously
or if they're allowed to adapt or if
they're only allowed to add data
those are insertion or injection models
and there are versions where they're at
cloud to delete and those are called
strong contamination models
that's more in the context of
unsupervised learning sometimes you'll
hear this called many different things
it'll be called the data poisoning
attack or it'll be called
model misspecification in a bunch of
settings
but even then there are a bunch of
richer things that i didn't talk about
because
you know what happens instead of the
adversary as moving you to another
distribution that's close in total
variation distance
i could honestly choose any distance
measure on probability distributions i
wanted
so if you chose the earth mover distance
that would be another way to set up
robust unsupervised learning
i don't start off with a gaussian but i
start off with something that's close
and a cruise mover
to a gaussian you know that's also a
perfectly valid noise model it actually
turns out to be way
easier than for the total variation
version
and then i talked about supervised
learning in this context so
you know here we only talked about
corruptions on the labels
so there was the random classification
noise where it's random there was
agnostic where it's completely arbitrary
and then there were mixed things in
between or the adversary was allowed
some adversarial control but
the points that he had within his
control were randomly scattered
but even then that's not the end of the
story because there's another cool one
where the adversary is allowed to tamper
not just with the y but also with the x
and that's called the malicious noise
model and there's some really nice work
uh
you know of uh awasti balkan and long on
these types of things which i encourage
you to check out
this is probably not even an exhaustive
list but
these are at least some popular ones
that i know
were the random forest results sensitive
to any parameters such as number of
trees use of bagging
actually they weren't we didn't try
bagging but the number of trees they
weren't that sensitive
as far as i can remember but one of the
things is that these random forest
results are not in extremely high
dimensions i mean we're talking about 14
attributes so you know an interesting
question is could you prove guarantees
about how
random forest works especially under
rich noise models
like massage or what have you but you
can also wonder even experimentally
whether these things
carry over the high dimensional settings
i don't think we really know the answer
to that but
you know random forests use a lot of
distances in how they decide to make
their decision boundary
and for a lot of high dimensional
problems that's where you know distances
without learning something about the
underlying structure of your data tend
not to be very useful things to do
see even if we go way back to my first
talk when i talked about learning
mixtures of spherical gaussians
then when you learn them they can
actually be incredibly overlapping
and what happens is that a sample from
one gaussian might actually very often
look like it's closer to the center of
the other gaussian
than it is to its own center but it's
only when you find the direction that
connects the centers of the means
that you find the right intrinsic
distance actually used to measure
you know how which points are close to
which other ones
so it's quite possible to me that some
of these random forest results
empirically that it's good
might go out the window in high
dimensions because maybe they're not
actually adapted to
you know the right notions of distance
in high dimensions
because of things like concentration and
measure phenomenon underneath it
there is a adam kleisen's there is a
paper by bylander about learning half
space as the noise rates
changing as you move the decision
boundary okay neat i'll have to check
this out i've seen a citation of this
but i've never actually read it
adam do you happen to know if there are
distributional assumptions on the
x's or i mean is it a mixture of like
distributional assumptions on x's and
noise rates that vary geometrically
or can you do distribution independent
and you know geometric noise
i think i don't think there's an
assumption on the distribution but
um there may be sort of a strong
assumption on how the noise
changes as you move towards the decision
boundary i can't quite remember
do you okay and i guess yeah i guess we
would have to check it but
i've certainly seen a bunch of settings
where the noise being parametric versus
non-parametric in this way like if it's
monotone versus
it is this particular monotone function
seems to
really change things especially when you
talk about like you know iterative
algorithms making progress towards the
correct thing but
i guess to be determined i don't quite
know
and i should also mention that there's
been a whole bunch of other
distribution dependents agnostic
learning
results so i only had time to tell you
at least a couple of the highlights like
the kkms paper and the adl
but you know there are results when you
talk about
x as gaussian x's uniform on the
hypercube
x is log concave a lot of those
distributions depend on things
at least certainly the first wave of
them use polynomial approximation as one
of their key pieces
so they're sort of using you know the
fact that you have fourier analysis and
orthogonal polynomials
but they use you know some very clever
l1 regression types of things to get
agnostic guarantees
and there's a big difference is that
when you get distribution dependent
agnostic learning results
you're shooting for something much
stronger which is i don't want eta plus
excel on agreement i want optiplus
epsilon
agreement which could conceivably be
you know much better and often is
actually
um uncle just a quick follow-up on on
the question that i asked about logistic
regression
can you hear me um okay awesome um
so just a quick clarification here and
it actually ties back into your
into what you were just saying about the
metric itself
but if i just wanted to estimate the
half space of if i just wanted to
estimate w
star in this model then
the rates for estimation should be less
sensitive
to non-parametric noise is that is the
intuition correct like i can still get
root n consistent estimates of the
parameter
um even if i have non-parametric noise
right i mean in the prediction
norm that you're considering it could be
much much worse
conceivably absolutely yeah i agree um i
don't know
uh a citation for that but that
certainly seems very consistent with my
intuition
um you know one of the distinctions just
to sort of elaborate a bit more on that
because i would still have to think a
bit about that particular noise model
but if you take the blum at all result
uh you know back from 90a
that actually doesn't just achieve low
error it does something better
because you know the best error you can
achieve in terms of agreement with the
wise observe
is you know ada right because there
really is ada noise that's added
but they actually do better because they
converge to the w star
so what's true there is that you know
anything that actually does achieve
small enough
error because the noise is actually
random will necessarily
you know get closer and closer to w star
so if you formulate these goals with
like
you know i mean certainly for random
noise models and for structured noise
models
there are fundamentally things that you
can do in terms of what
problem i can solve that you can't do in
some of the other things where it's
you know impossible in some of the miss
art like noise models and stuff i think
ah so the actual parameter recovery is
impossible in the massage model is what
you just said
yeah i think so i have to i i have to
double check
um but i remember some discussions about
this but
that is the type of thing that these
noise models might you know cost you is
that sometimes
you can actually solve a stronger
problem like parameter recovery in the
random thing
or the structured noise thank you
and what is known about proper learning
in the agnostic model with
distributional assumptions
so you know i'm likely going to have to
tell you like a caricature of an answer
and then
maybe i can defer to clivens if he's
still here
but one thing that i didn't talk about
is this danielle
result if i remember correctly so first
of all it's awesome because it's
a weak agnostic learning lower bound
it's hard to go from 99
you know as the promise even 51 that
sucks
and in fact um you know it really does
use the fact that it's a very
tailor-made and kind of strange
distribution because it comes from some
random csp assumptions
um but it's also hardness if i remember
correctly for
improper agnostic learning and
there's a big difference that um you
know when you talk about hardness of
proper agnostic learning
you can actually prove things uh you
know based on empty hardness
and these are maybe some of the old blum
and revest papers from way back when
but when you're talking about proving
hardness of improper learning
that's a much trickier beast there are
reasons why you wouldn't
expect it to be based on hard you know
empty hardness
and you know some of the really
important work here is like uh the
cliven suresoft paper
that showed hardness i think in a
distribution independent a distribution
independent way so you know for a very
you know i mean a particular
distribution that comes out of crypto
but they showed hardness of improperly
learning intersections of half spaces
for example
and um you know there it was really
based on some of these ideas about if
you could solve the learning problem
regardless of what hypothesis you output
you know because it's improper
you would then be able to break various
lattice-based crypto schemes
now i don't know so in already in your
question when you have
proper learning you can do a lot
stronger things here because
you know even when you talk about
distribution independent you're in the
realm of potentially basing things on
empty hardness
as opposed to basing it on crypto
but i don't know of very much for proper
learning
in agnostic model with distributional
assumptions
um yeah so i mean it's um
for the for the district if you take a
distributional assumption like i think
the awash
on long paper i think it is proper
you'll get order opt plus epsilon
now if um if you want to do
um opt plus epsilon
and and it's a gaussian uh being
proper is open it's still open and um
amit danielle has this p
task for
getting close to op plus epsilon under
distribution assumption but that's also
not proper
any more questions
all right so if there's no more
questions thank you again ankur
and we'll see you all at the coffee
break
in the garden i'll say uh one last thing
that uh my next talk it'll get even
weirder so
we'll see it'll be even more wild
quantification so if you prefer
fewer theorems and more wild
pontifications be ready
we're going to go into physics